عبد السلام احد التصريحات اللافته اليوم
لاداره الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه وصفت ما
تعرضت له تركيا او هذه الولايات العشر
التي تعرضت للدمار بسبب هذا الزلزال وصفت
حجم الدمار بانه يعادل التعرض للقصب
بقنابل نوويه
والحقيقه نحن نشاهد المشهد على الارض
ويبدو ان هذا التوصيف دقيق هذا الشارع
مثلا في مدينه كرمان مرعش ربما جوله فيه
توحي فعلا بان هذا الزلزال قد غير شكل
المدينه ومعالمها وحجم الدمار حقيقه كبير
وربما هذا المشهد قد يستمر لايام وايام
بسبب البطء وهنا قد يكون بطئ متعمد للعمل
لرفع يعني هذه الجرافات مثلا لان تحاول ان
تتقدم عمليات رفع الانقاذ بحذر لان هناك
حتى الان ما تزال المخاوف من وجود او
ناجين تحت هذه الانقاض قبل ساعه تقريبا
توقفت الاشغال هنا لانه تم محاوله التواصل
مع احد مع الناجين المحتمرين في هذا
المبنى توقفت الاشغال بعد ذلك تتقدم ببطء
وسبب في ذلك انه حتى اليوم السادس حتى بعد
مرور 120 ساعه على الزلزال ما يزال
المسعفون وعمال الانقاذ يجدون او ينقذون
اشخاص اخرين اليوم في مدينه كرمان مرعش تم
يعني انقاذ طفل في سنته الاولى والسيده في
عمرها السبعين معنى ان هناك طيف واسع من
الاعمار يتم انقاذه وهذا ربما يسبب هذا
البطء في عمليه رفع القادمه خافت ان تتقدم
هذه الجرافات وتزيد من تعقيد الوضع
بالنسبه
للناجين الموجودين في تحت الانقاذ في هذا
الشارع قبل ساعه ونصف تقريبا كانت هناك
جوله للمبعوثه الاممي ومنسق الاستجابه
للطوارئ مارت
صحفيه وصف فيها من هول ربما ما راه قال
بان زلزال كهرمان مرعش يوم الاثنين الماضي
كان اسوا حادثه تشهدها المنطقه في اكثر من
مئه سنه كلام كبير من مسؤول اممي وربما ما
راه دفعه لقول ما قاله
اشاد في الحقيقه بمقال ما قامت به تركيا
حتى الان وقال بان استجابتها خلال 24 ساعه
الماضيه واستجابه المجتمع الدولي خلال 24
ساعه الاولى ما بعد الزلزال كانت مثاليه
واستثنائيه تعهد بالدعوه الى مؤتمر لجمع
التبرعات
ويعني تقديم الدعم سواء لتركيا او لسوريا
قال بان الواضح حتى الان ليس واضح لكنه
تعهد
بالدعوه لهذا المؤتمر وهو دعم تحتاجه
تركيا وتحتاجه سوريا بالنظر الى حجم
الدمار
نقطه فقط لافته يعني عبد السلام جميع هذه
المباني الموجوده في هذا الشارع تضررت
بشكل اما كل او جزئي المبنى الذي على يمين
الكاميرا يعني تصدع ولم يعد قابلا للسكن
وهي مساله وقت فقط لا يمكن ان يعود احد
ليسكن في هذا المحل مساله وقت فقط قبل ان
تقرر السلطات هدمه لانه لم يعد صالحا
للبناء المباني التي نراها على مد البصر
كلها تقوم يعني اما تدمرت بشكل كلي او
جزئي باستثناء هذا المبنى بالاحمر والابيض
المفارقه انه مبنى مقر نقابه المهندسين في
مدينه كهرمان مرعش وكان محطه تندر من قبل
يعني رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الذين
قالوا بانه المباني كلها الخاصه يعني
المباني الخاصه سواء سكنيه او التجاريه
تعرضت للدمار باستثناء مبنى نقابه
المهندسين يبدو انهم قاموا بعملهم كما
ينبغي وهذا في اشاره واضحه الى ما لمحت
وصرحت به
كبير من المسؤولين الاتراك سواء الرئيس
التركي وزير العدل اليوم والنائب العام
قبل ايام عندما قال بان هناك شبهه لان عدد
من المتعهدين او المتعاقدين الذين يقومون
ببناء المنازل ومباني السكنيه قد قاموا
باستعمال مواد مغشوشه او حديد قليل في
المبنى او اسمنت غير مسلح وبالتالي سوف
تتم فتح تحقيقات متابعه المسؤولين عن يعني
هذه الاعمال التي ادت في نهايه المطاف الى
رفع الكلفه البشريه لهذا الزلزال وهناك
حديث عن منع عدد من المتعاقدين من السفر
اغلاق المنافذ البريه في وجوههم في انتظار
اتضاح الصوره يبدو فعلا ان موضوع
النزاهه فيما يتعلق بعمل المتعاقدين الذين
تكلفوا ببناء هذه المنازل سوف يكون محل
نقاش واسع بين الاتراك خلال المرحله
المقبله بالنظر الى الارتفاع الكبير في
الكلفه البشريه لهذا الزلزال عبد السلام